[Music]
all right we're back
you were back i had a feeling something
was gonna happen because i saw
that the chat had stopped for like a
minute or two and usually when that
starts to happen i start getting very
nervous
yeah we don't know why it happens i
don't know it's weird it's
beyond caring at this point
[Laughter]
didn't do it before yeah pookie being
weird she keeps like
yeah she keeps um coming in here
yeah and asking me to go with her she's
like i need you to come with me like
right now i'm gonna go what i thought
she's gonna go outside she goes no
no i want to go outside yeah and i just
want you to come with me yeah
somewhere she wants me to go with her
somewhere i don't know where
i'm you know what i'm telling you right
now she's been a really good girl
while mommy and daddy have been sick
because normally she would be
what
because normally she would be like being
a little brat
yeah like because she can't go outside
because if we can't really
i don't like her to go outside she
really only goes in the backyard
or sometimes in the neighbors but i
don't really like her to go outside
unless we're kind of around
like to supervise her and like you know
look out and see where she's at
every few minutes um and you know we
were sick so we didn't want to get out
of bed so it's just kind of like man i
don't want her to go outside because i
don't want to have to get up and check
on her she knew we were sick
and yeah so she was actually really good
she did do one bratty thing where she
was just kind of like mad and she kind
of
she came up on uh on your nightstand
and she was just kind of like like
knocked something off yeah like
like knocks your wallet off like your
metal wallet but that's kind of all she
did other than that she kind of got it
and um you know she just came up and i
think she slept between my feet most of
last night okay we got about 20 in there
we can
start talking about it again um all
right so um
with coming to america
is it a bad movie no no it's pretty good
movie actually was better than i was
expecting yeah it's pretty good movie
i thought it was a little long like some
stuff could have been trimmed and i
thought like the plot could have been
simplified i think that was my main idea
i think
i think t got it right too it should
have been r rated that too
um i wouldn't they're worried i wouldn't
worry about the [ __ ]
woke messaging you don't need that um
it's just just unnecessary and they
shouldn't have been
uh and like i said most of the messaging
didn't have anything to do with the real
world it was more like apologizing for
what happened
in the first movie man [ __ ] that just
make the goddamn movie um look at her
what's she doing look at that [ __ ] the
camera get the camera
okay hold on no it spoiled it because
she looked away she's like she's laying
on her back like that
she's still doing it she still do it get
the camera over there
look pookie
look get over a little bit
look at that
look at her little belly oh my god
okay both are little fishies i bought
her
and beijing those little floppy fishies
for christmas both of them are broken
now
like the they still work like they still
make the noise like the
rare noise but they it doesn't flop
anymore because like the
the armature broke in there tom fixed it
like the first time but then after he's
like [ __ ] i'm not fixing it again she
keeps sitting on it
like she's trying to kick it at the same
time and she just like sits on it and
she broke the armature so
now it just makes the noise and doesn't
flop tammy said that i pissed wesley
snipes off
he made the stream drop yeah [ __ ] you
guys no
who knew how powerful wesley snipes
could be he's general izzy
[ __ ] snipes is [ __ ] in great shape
for his age think about it
he's at least he's at least 60 he's 60
something at least oh yeah
somebody can check that check it out
he's in good shape for his age
um it's just that now we're gonna get
okay
so let's talk about blade now what i
want to say too dj maniac just said as i
was saying in the last chat snipes was a
diva during blade two and three
just sat in his trailer getting high and
skipping the dailies they had the cgi
sixty percent of his performance
he's got like [ __ ] i don't even wanna
be in these [ __ ] movies
my understanding that was in blade three
though that wasn't in two
i think that was just three that he was
doing that and that's because he knew
blade three was gonna be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bomb which it was because they were
just what they were trying to do is
actually start a new franchise
they got the new director wanted to
introduce three new characters they were
like vampire type hunters
and he was going to introduce them and
make a whole series based around them
not blade so what it's kind of like he
was
piggybacking his project onto the blade
project he's like well i want to do some
vampire [ __ ] too
but yeah this [ __ ] cat this dog yeah
that's the cat dog
yeah it's the neighbor's dog right
outside the window
yeah let me see we [ __ ] the camera up
because we were
she always looks at us like because
every time she does that we're always
like oh look and she's like
why are you looking at me i'm just
laying here like a very normal little
fuzzy person if you do
if you do blade you might as well start
in brandon blade
and you got to find the leading man that
can do that can carry that role
which i you just got to find the right
guy i don't know if the right guy's out
there right now he's got
one he's got to be black but two he's
got to have the gravitas and he's got to
have the [ __ ] physicalities to pull
it off
and he's got to have the [ __ ]
charisma you got to have a [ __ ]
action background
but he's also got to be able to act and
you want him to be young
you know what i mean that way you can
get a lot of a lot of movies out of it
you wanted to be in his mid-20s yeah
you know so
you got to find out who's out there you
know i can't think of anybody i haven't
seen blade in such a long time
one of these days i'll say somebody you
know who
you know who might be you know who would
be a good blade probably the dude who
played luke cage
oh yeah i love that guy he was
[ __ ] great as luke cage i feel like i
i feel like i know his name and it just
totally slipped my mind
he's got yeah i agree he would actually
be really he's got the charisma
you know what i mean he's a big guy uh
but he's kind of got a heroic kind of uh
i thought idris elba as well because in
the comic book blade is
british and idris elba is also those
guys are too old
he is a bit older but the guy from blue
cage might be a little i don't know
how i'm not sure how old he is actually
yeah tila says i still use snipes coin
and blade some [ __ ] always
trying to ice skate uphill
yeah right yeah who do you think t
who's out there he's got to be he's got
to be kind of young though
do you think that dude who played uh
luke cage could do that
i feel like didn't the last time i saw
the dude from luke cage
wasn't he in that weird christian movie
remember he was i didn't see the
christian movie but i saw the trailer
remember the one about the kid that when
he fall through the ice or some [ __ ]
like that it was based on our true story
and then they were like we prayed real
hard and he came back to life even
though everybody said he wasn't going to
i feel like luke cage was in that but he
played like a nurse or something
i'll tell you what t there's a rumor
going around
that uh they're gonna make
basically a black superman movie where
superman's black
i think it's ha that could
they're i think it's a bad idea and a
great idea at the same time
because what they're talking about is
making clark kent
black that's a bad idea you see there's
an expanded universe
there's another version of superman
called uh red sun
and the idea was is what would happen
if superman had had fallen into the
soviet union during the time of stalin
what would happen how would superman how
would he be different
he had been a communist superman and how
would that have gone down
there's a really good animated movie uh
i think it might still be on netflix
called red sun we saw it on i think we
rented it on xbox
maybe that's what we did or so maybe
it's on amazon prime too t if you
haven't seen red sun
that was really really good animated but
animated but it's
played right like alternate universe
universe
it's my understanding that there's an
extended universe where
there was an now and here's the thing
when when when jarrell
when he fell to earth and landed landed
in soviet union he wasn't
he wasn't clark kent because he wasn't
found by the same family so he didn't
get that name
he wasn't a reporter he was very
different because that
it wouldn't have gone down that way in
the soviet union
so red's son was not clark kent and he's
not the superman that you know
is he a hero
depends on which way you look i look at
it you're right that's that's the good
thing about that
what i don't know everything about this
but i'd heard
that there is another extended universe
where a super baby does fall to the
ground and he is black
it's not a super baby yeah it's not
clark kent though and it's not quite the
same universe
i don't know if it's taking place in an
african country or what well like oracle
says they have a whole like marvel or
uh dc or whatever has that kind of whole
like extended what's it called
elseworlds or
yeah yeah so it's i feel like comics
lines they have a lot more
leeway to play with alternate universe
all right
storyline my advice is to these people
making
black superman do not take the white
superman
and make him black because there's no
comic book that matches that
find the alternate version and make that
comic book into a movie
because then it will have it will have
the canonical
credibility it's a can you know what i
mean it has to be something from canon
you know what i mean yeah because it was
a comic book
comic book right so you're not
reinterpreting clark kent
you're going for the original work yeah
just like
red sun was an original work yeah and
that could work
if it if you ask me black superman
really is nick cage
and then he goes excuse me luke cage
mango says there is a black superman in
the dc multiverse
yeah right somebody said before i was
trying to
uh i was trying to say they're rebooting
blade with um
marshall ali who was in the guy from
green book he's been on a ton of other
things yeah he was great in predators
yeah yeah he was in that and on the back
he played that african death squad dude
and remember that yeah and he could he
was giving a [ __ ]
so he could probably do it yeah he could
probably do it that's i think that's
who's going to play him
yeah in the next ones he's a little old
but yeah you know what are you gonna do
he's got the gravitas he needs
that's the thing if you have an actor
that's too young
they don't have they don't have the
[ __ ] rap yeah they don't have like a
lot of [ __ ] to like back it up you know
what i mean so i think i feel like you
need somebody a little bit older
yeah because what was it a green book is
that what it's called
yeah yeah we saw that in the theater
that was an excellent movie we did yeah
it
was
kind of like i think it won the oscar
thing it's like a bloody road trip movie
[ __ ] going in the south [ __ ]
yeah the gangster in this [ __ ] and it
was all it was based on a true story if
you guys haven't seen that one see that
that's a really good
really good uh uh story good movie
yeah i like that movie quite a bit but
just thought on the back of that movie
and on the back of predators
which is like what predator three now do
predator four
are we talking about like alien versus
predator
i guess that would have been predator
three on the back
he was he played a a dude in a would
then the aliens took him from from an
african death squad
wasn't africa it was
i was i might have been off one of those
islands
i've got what kind sierra leone and so
negative
sierra leone that might that isn't on
the continent of africa i think in it
as far as i can remember i remember
that's where they got him
from i mean there's a comic book about
what they were all doing before they got
picked the thing about it is that both
marvel and dc because somebody pointed
out that you know
uh dc has elseworlds and marvel has what
if
yeah where you take the characters and
then you write like alternate versions
of them like a spin-off
and um so i feel like there's so much of
that just kind of how i always feel like
you know there are so many great
horror novels out there why don't people
adapt
i mean it's it's better now than it used
to be because i feel like you know in
the 90s and early 2000s it was all let's
remake everything or you know let's
make a see the 50 millionth sequel to
this [ __ ] movie
but i do feel like there's a lot more
original material out there at least in
the horror kind of [ __ ] but i feel like
there's so many
books out there so many comic books out
there that you could adapt i mean
if you needed like source material like
there's [ __ ] you'd never run out
you wouldn't yeah i think it's supposed
to be jj abrams gonna make this black
superman movie with the dude
i think it's a dude that wrote all those
uh
horror movies like us jordan peele i
think it's short i think it's jordan
peele
i can't wait to see jordan peels candy i
think even though well it's not a remake
it's a sequel
but i think it was jordan peele yeah
maybe it wasn't jordan peele
but for some reason i kind of think it
was but they're going to make this black
superman and they should not
make a black hand they should
use a [ __ ] original story kind of
like
out of those alternate universes yeah
like they did with red sun yeah because
when you see it
you're not it's a character that's
riding on the back of its own
credibility
it's from canon you know what i mean
listen because if you don't do it that
way then you're saying well we want
people to come see a
a black superhero movie and we can't
make up a [ __ ] black
superheroes good enough that these white
people will go see so we'll
just make superman black and all these
white people go see that's
that's a cheap way of [ __ ] doing it
that's saying that people will not go
see a black
superhero unless he has a [ __ ] famous
name attached to it
that's not true yeah i think it's more
like
they they they're afraid well we need
name recognition yeah but i think that
was the problem
particularly um like i said i think it's
better not east
because i feel like particularly in the
horror genre like i said which is kind
of my area of expertise i guess
but um i feel like that's what was going
on in the 90s and 2000s where you saw
all these remakes it's like we're just
going to remake you know popular asian
horror movies we're going to remake all
these movies in the 70s
because they had name recognition
they're like that's how we get butts and
seats
if we just come up with an original idea
no one's going to give a [ __ ] it's going
to be like harder
to get any recognition for it but this
is something that already has
like some cultural caching like built in
but
that has you know yeah that can help
because people be like oh i've heard of
that but i feel like that's not really
the way to go
situation anymore internet [ __ ]
changed the game
oh yeah but here's okay the black
panther movie
was [ __ ] hugely successful mostly
white people saw it
everyone saw that yeah i feel like yeah
[ __ ] ticket sales white people saw
that every one of the [ __ ] plans
they'll see a black hero look how good
the [ __ ] luke cage [ __ ]
uh series was on netflix we watched that
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] great
oh yeah that was good yeah that he
and he was like that that dude is like
such a great actor i want to see him
with more stuff i want to
say like i said it kind of bums me out
that the last thing that i think that i
saw him in was the trailer for that
terrible looking christian
i stopped watching i stopped watching
those uh series
when uh they came out with the punisher
when the punisher first appeared
in [ __ ] uh daredevil season two
i was [ __ ] jacked i go that is the
[ __ ] punisher
and then he came out with his own
[ __ ] series
boy they watered that character down
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] weak
all right i like i'm not sure i liked
that better than iron fist though i
won't say
yeah but iron physically at least iron
fist yeah the problem is
that the punisher is an anti well
he's a dark anti-hero he's the kind of
dude that will hang
his enemies up on me hooks he'll torture
people
he's not trying to be good he's just
trying to kill people
kill evil people that's what he's trying
to do and they didn't want that
you know that's not what they wanted but
that's what that character is
they didn't want to promote that idea
but
the punisher wasn't really a good guy
the punisher was actually a bad guy
in a way it he was just so more
depends on he was the moral
it was morally gray well the thing about
it is i feel like you could really get
away with [ __ ] because people watch
you know morally questionable characters
uh all the time
yeah you know what i mean what doesn't
mean you see you like them or you
sympathize with them
just you know what i mean and what i
loved about the [ __ ] punisher
is that they got it right the [ __ ]
skull on the [ __ ]
on the front of his armor was that the
[ __ ] x-ray of his head
injury his superpower was [ __ ]
traumatic brain injury and [ __ ]
ptsd and all that training that's what
his superpower was
yeah they got it that's what it is in
fact when i saw that [ __ ] and
when he first appeared in the daredevil
i'm going damn that's how i used to feel
that's how i used to [ __ ] feel yeah
that [ __ ]
two years after that [ __ ] head injury
you're like that
yeah yeah you know
[Laughter]
i did a really um other than i mean i
liked punisher i didn't like it as much
as i mean if i had to rank the ones that
we saw
man it's probably like a three-way tie
for number one for daredevil
luke cage and jessica jones yeah jessica
jones was good too i love
jessica jones yes and then then punisher
then iron fest
i watched iron fist some of it was good
but it's just kind of i don't know i
didn't find that dude all that
compelling
i guess what yeah the iron fist guy it
was
it was enough to keep me watching the
whole series but he wasn't as cool as
daredevil he wasn't as cool as luke cage
he wasn't as cool as jessica jones
i mean jessica jones she's like my
spirit animal yeah i was i was
into that they just [ __ ] up they just
[ __ ] up the puniture
you know in his own series they they had
him right in the daredevil
but they [ __ ] him up in his own series
it was [ __ ] not good
and they had the right actor and
everything yeah john bernthal has been
great that's exactly who that should
have been it was just great on walking
down the direction that they did with
that [ __ ] character he should have
been
much more violent and uh
and he should have just been a lot more
morally gray
i mean he's he's straight up vigilante
you know
and a mass murderer basically yeah he
was just waging a one-man war on
organized crime
because nobody else could you know he's
like well i guess i'm just gonna
yeah that's [ __ ] about vengeance you
know
jacqueline says i'm late with my comment
because i paused the video but it's so
funny you said your cat loves the smell
of bleach
because my cat jasper loves it too and i
wonder who's just a weirdo or what
i think that there is a subset of
cabinets
because i thought it was i thought
beijing had some i was like what's wrong
with her what is she doing like why is
she like rolling around in the [ __ ]
on the bleach floor and um i looked it
up and apparently there is a small
subset of i
i don't know if it's certain like
species because they did like
specifically mention ragdoll which she
is
um but i think there's a couple other
breeds too that they're like yeah for
some reason they're super into the smell
of bleach and like i said she reacts
just like [ __ ] catnip
she's she rolls around like a little
fuzzy crazy nuts
she's just
become one with the damn mop head
yeah try to get in the mop and just oh
it's just weird i have a little bit of
video i was trying to get some video
like one time i cleaned the bathroom and
like i said i was trying to keep her out
of there but she was rolling around
on the bath mat that i guess had some
bleach smell on it and then i was
like get out of the bathroom get out and
then she was rolling around like on the
carpet that was like right by the
bathroom
and i got a little bit of video there
because i had to run and get the video
because i'm like oh my god look what the
[ __ ] she's doing i have to like look for
that [ __ ] video somewhere i don't
remember what i did with it
but holy crap now catnip my boys start
wrestling they love nip yeah our little
kitties love nip too
yeah sophie i thought that he he's
absolutely great in the [ __ ] dared
in the daredevil but it's weak sauce his
own series with weak sauce
they tried to play that [ __ ] too safe
and
i don't really know why they did that
there's a lot of veterans [ __ ]
running around and maybe they didn't
want to inspire dudes to do that to do
that
and maybe that's what it was there's no
telling
yeah i don't really know but like i said
i liked a lot of those
you know like i said other than i i just
feel like the later ones just weren't as
good maybe it just wasn't
and even the second season of jessica
jones i really liked it wasn't as good
as the first one because like you know
the doctor who dude that was playing
like the mind control guy that like that
was a pretty
that's kind of a hard david tennant
right it was david
um that's kind of a hard villain to top
but
man now i want to watch the first season
of jessica jones again
i don't think i watched that one twice i
think i watched the first season of
daredevil twice because i think i
watched the first season again like when
the second season came out
and i think i did the same with luke
cage i think i watched the first season
again win the second one but i don't
know
if that was jessica jones i was like i
can't remember none of these projects
can last forever it's hard to keep the
energy levels high
[ __ ] other motives get involved and
the bigger the production the more
meddling sometimes it'll happen
from higher well and sometimes too like
the more creative
visions you have conflicting with one
another
and sometimes you have to kind of water
everything down to get to make everybody
happy or keep everybody from like
walking off
yeah so sometimes stuff gets kind of
that's why
in a lot of ways and this isn't always
the case um you know sometimes you get
happy accidents but sometimes the more
people are working on
the [ __ ] worse it's going to be you know
or at least like the more bland it is
yeah you know what i mean because like i
said there's just too many egos involved
there's too many people that want their
thing
and it's like no i want this thing and
they're like arguing about it
and i just feel like i don't know
usually something that's just like the
vision of one person or just a couple of
people
even if those people conflict sometimes
that can make something better but the
more people you get involved
the more likely it's gonna be that it's
not gonna be i mean it might not be
terrible but i don't think it's going to
be like
and the kind of fantastic and the kind
of people that you have in these second
creative companies that make all this
[ __ ] the type of people that it's
attracted over the years
who's coming out of these universities
who they're recruiting and everything
these [ __ ] are touchy
they're touchy and finicky and they
fight each other
and they their jealousy a lot of
jealousy is a lot of petty [ __ ]
just look at what's happening with
[ __ ] disney you know
they're factions inside of disney at war
with one another over [ __ ] star wars
you know uh and then that shit's gonna
get destroyed
you know i think depends you know i'm
really hoping that
boba fett and some of these other little
series that they're coming out with
hopefully they're going to be really
good but
i kind of doubt it i don't i think uh i
think disney's in over its head
and um
disney is not a healthy company um
there's people that have really kind of
who are in the financial industry
who i listen to a lot of shows you know
one of the best ones is uh
midnight's edge and then
that's a good one and it's a channel on
youtube
and uh it's a collection of a whole
bunch of guys who are in this industry
and they're all talking about it
or they're at least admirers of the
industry and they have
fans who are in these industries that
slip them information a lot
and a lot of stuff about disney
corporation has been slipped out lately
it's
in a financial guy came forward and said
that he'd looked at a lot of the stuff
that disney does
and and what it does in public and what
and how it trades on the market
and what happens in [ __ ] certain
advent stock
you know investor or [ __ ] things that
happen
and he said that uh disney disney
exhibits the behavior of a company
that is not financially healthy
that a company that mostly survives on
the back of its
uh stock market activities because
that's
so what that usually means is that
it's not making money with the products
that it makes
it makes money off the stock that's
traded
so it's kind of like a ponzi scheme
it's money it's value is only
based upon the fact that people believe
it's worth something
not really what it's selling it's pr
probably not in good financial health
the the parks are not doing well it's
streaming service
evidently is not doing well it looks
like it's doing well on a surface
but they said that that data is very
easy to rig
because it's electronic data and you can
hire
companies to kind of make you look
really good when you get put put under
the microscope to make it look like
you have more subscribers than you do
more subscriptions than you actually
do and that you have more traffic than
you actually do there's ways around all
that
so um it's not gonna take it wouldn't
take
much it doesn't take much to topple in
entertainment
companies uh all you have to do is to uh
make them unpopular because their value
is only based in popularity
and as soon as they as soon as the
audience turns against them there's
nothing left you know and that's that's
what happens to most you
that's why most your hollywood studios
are gone and they this a lot of them
disappeared
you know back in the 90s and then the
2000s a lot of them went out of business
and got catalyzed by other
other studios just you don't really hear
that much about it because you don't pay
attention you know but um
i don't think disney's gonna make it
based on everything i'm seeing
i think it may i think it'll make it
maybe three or four years
yeah sophie was saying earlier that um
that she tends to just like watch series
for a few seasons and then kind of
fizzles out on it
and she said well maybe that's just me
but i was like i don't think it is
though i think after a while
they get bad yeah it's like it's not
even that it's just kind of like
when you're first really into it like
you're watching the thing and you get in
all the characters and then like as the
story goes on you know maybe some of
your characters die
or you know all the exciting [ __ ] that
happened to these particular character
that happened already and it's like now
we're just repeating stuff and it's like
now there's these new people and we
don't like them as much
so it's just kind of like i think that's
kind of um that kind of happens with
every
series i mean for a while look how long
we watched
the walking dead and then i
we loved that [ __ ] we like watched it
every [ __ ] weekend and then
or whenever it was on and then after a
while we just kind of forgot about
it but i mean we stuck with that for
probably like five six
maybe seven seasons and then after a
while i was just kind of like ah cause
most of the
most of our favorite characters were
dead and like you know
i was just kind of like i don't know if
there's enough of my favorite characters
left on there to like
even bother watching it anymore and like
i said i'm really i like series but
if they go on too long there's just
there's only so much
you can do it's going to start repeating
itself or you're going to have to kill
off some of the characters and it's like
i don't know
i just i can't get into it you know i
feel like
maybe it's better to do kind of because
i feel like british tv has more of a
thing where it's like
look we're just going to make two two
seasons of this and then
we're calling it off and we're going to
like make something else
you know what i mean they tend not to
other than soap operas
you know which go on forever just like
the ones here do
like for [ __ ] 40 years um you know
when they do series like the office or
something like that they just
they do two seasons and then they end it
well they're all talking about now it's
like walking dead
yeah the walking dead is fantastic uh
for about four or five seasons
six seasons maybe but the reason why it
was fantastic is because people were
getting killed
people were getting killed as soon as
they stopped killing people you're like
well
you know why am i watching this because
what's what it started off as a as a
good
survival horror you know what i mean
show where
people who did the wrong thing got
killed by their own
you know well that's what i'm talking
about it's like after a while
like watching people like fight zombies
exciting watching people
farm not exactly yeah right it's like
you know it's nothing against people
that farm everybody needs farmers
but one wants to watch a series about
that it's like we want to watch a series
about people fighting zombies
thoughts getting to where you start
running into people who are role-playing
knowing people that are acting
pretending that they're ants in a
junkyard people
are pretending that they're in it
they're getting a little weird
they're in a medieval [ __ ] uh kingdom
and uh it's
the the brutality of it went away and it
was because
i guess they realized that eventually
they were gonna have to kill daryl
and they were gonna you know what i mean
and they didn't want to do that and
everyone would stop watching
it right so but instead of just bringing
in new people that were interesting and
killing them
and keeping the ones that people liked
you know what i mean they just
they didn't handle it right
it went from survival horror to soap
opera i mean
somebody told me that the last i don't
know if it was the last season the one
before last was actually really good and
i should probably go back because i
think that was the one they brought in
the whisperers and all that
um so somebody said oh it got good again
but i don't know i'll probably go back
and
watch it all again at some point but i
think i don't know i i kind of got
bummed out
you know after they killed glenn and
then after
rick left i was just you know daryl and
carol were still there and i love them
but i was just kind of like
[Music]
i don't know and then it seemed like and
then it seemed like there were too many
characters
i mean i know that they were like
started with characters so they had more
cannon fodder so they could like people
could get killed
but a lot of the new characters they
introduced okay that's fine if you want
to get them
you know have more people get killed by
zombies but
then you have less time to focus on the
characters that everybody likes
you know what i mean so it gets like too
sprawling no
what the problem was with the walking
dead and this is also happened with uh
well that was my perception of the
problem that was what i didn't like
about yeah
there's there there's a more fundamental
problem the problem with the walking
dead what was that other one
fear the walking dead yeah yeah that's
better okay
the problem with them is that the people
that were doing the writing
okay wanted inclusion and representation
in other words every person of the food
group would be represented
in the movie but the problem
with that with that is that in a
situation
of dire survival in a zombie apocalypse
inclusion and diversity stops working
because the only people selected for
survival
are [ __ ] high level [ __ ]
sociopaths and psychopaths
that's who make it nice people don't
make it they'd all be dead
after a couple years what would be left
was gangs
and cartels and they would all be kind
of cross between
they would be paramilitary or they would
be
like a drug cartel or they would be like
outlaw bikers
or they would be you know what i mean
they would all be
young because the old would be too weak
to survive uh they'd be reproducing at a
pretty high rate too
to replenish their ranks uh they'd be
mobile
they'd be moving around a lot probably
or if they did
live in an area it would be a fortified
castle
they wouldn't be there for very long
it's just that
you all start ending up with a [ __ ]
um
some type of a warrior type mentality
and uh so there goes your inclusion and
diversity well and that would be boring
too i don't want to watch that
it's like that's what you would have i
know but i'm just saying if i wanted to
watch that i would watch like sons of
anarchy
closest thing that where i think they
probably got it right would be like
um i mean that works as a movie yeah
like as a series it was just boring
because it'd be like oh this group of
[ __ ] is going to fight this group
and then like the zombies attack right
rinse and repeat
so it's you can't win like if you go on
too long you can't win there's nothing
more you can do
it would be like just look at you know
when you look at the old west
you know the main [ __ ] it was all
badasses if you weren't a badass you
were just killed
you know especially out on the range
especially
in the on the great plains you had that
was that was like living on the high
seas
you know what i mean if somebody saw you
and that you wanted their tribe they
killed you
yeah so it would be a situation like
that
yeah somebody everybody's talking about
the new um now is it going to be a new
season of dexter are they rebooting it
like are they starting over i thought it
was like a new season man
that was a good series if you guys if
you guys have not seen dexter
yeah a lot of people are talking about
how [ __ ] great that was a lot of
people didn't like the last
season how it ended like i get it better
it ended a lot better than a lot of
other series went down it did not go
down like a [ __ ]
it didn't go down but not like a [ __ ]
that's that's one
i didn't mind it i can see why a lot of
people hated the way it ended but
i apparently they're doing a new season
and they're filming it now so
um a lot of people are hyped about it
i'm kind of hyped about it because i
[ __ ] love dexter
um but you know tila says me and the
hubs are watching the old
dark shadow series the one with jonathan
frid that's the vampire oh uh
that's what the uh he played uh what was
it
one of the scotlands yeah they remade
that in the 90s
i saw the originals the originals the
problem with the originals is that you
could skip
20 of them and not miss anything it
would uh
it would look like a soap opera you
could just kind of like you know
kind of went on forever it's kind of
like star trek in the sense that you
don't really have to watch them in order
but they were good though yeah so you
could kind of come in at any time but as
long as you kind of had an idea of who
the characters were and
what the situation was like you could
just kind of pick it up at any time like
star trek was kind of like that too
i think they made a lot of um shows like
that back then
just because i don't think i don't know
like back when they made dark shadows
you know back shows that came out in the
60s 50s and 60s
i kind of feel like they didn't have
much of a concept of
someone like binge watching a show like
you know a series the same way that you
would watch a movie
that was like a continuing story kind of
i kind of feel like it was more like
episodic
in the sense that well we have these
characters that have these traits
and this is the situation that they're
in and then we're just going to write
like a standalone
thing to happen to them over 30 minutes
or an hour or whatever and it doesn't
matter
like if you watch them in order or not
whereas series nowadays you kind of have
to watch them in order otherwise you
have no [ __ ] idea what's going on
because it's just watching the long ass
it's like watching a long-ass movie
people are telling me to watch
barbarians i'm gonna watch that one too
for you for some of you guys that may be
showing up late uh
jenny and i are also uh re-watching um
sparky spartacus
the first season for 2010. we've seen
the first two seasons
yeah and uh it was excellent first two
seasons
yeah like i said very much like 300. if
you really like 300 you probably did
yeah you don't see much writing like
that anymore this is just it's just good
hardcore
right that i love all this wearing
that's my
kind of opportunity to roman culture the
roman values are there
and like i said batiatus and lucy
lawless
oh yeah
oh my god all right so um do you want to
like wrap it up you seem like you're
starting to come out yeah
i'm getting i'm getting tired yeah i
mean you're still kind of sick
and i don't wanna he hadn't you haven't
been coughing too much you were coughing
pretty much all last night
yeah i got some kind of infection yeah
stemmed from
whatever the [ __ ] shit's mostly
inhaled some kind of particles or
something
yikes inhaling particles no one wants to
do that
but yeah so i guess we'll wrap it up and
it's super super long but we've been
going for like an hour 45 minutes
something like that
but i think we did good for you being as
ill as you have yeah
i feel better though i'm feeling better
in a couple yeah you seem like you're
you're feeling better today than you
were yeah yeah
all right so i guess we'll wrap it up
for this evening uh thanks everybody for
dropping by
and uh we're gonna do our live episode
on
friday evening at six right we decided
we're gonna do them at six now
yeah we're gonna do it friday night at
six uh i think it's gonna be about the
columbine
shooting yeah yeah gee check out that
red sun you got that thing on your list
it's not long man you need to check that
out tonight you'd like that
yeah i really it's good yeah some of
these animated superhero movies are real
good
and if you haven't seen shazam that's
reason that's actually my favorite
superhero movie of recent
shazam was so fun just good it was fun
that's
to me that's what a superhero movie it
was so fun yeah
uh but yeah so we're gonna do the show
on friday like i said the movie
retrospective that i already recorded
that is going up on friday which is
going to be
about the little girl that lives the
little girl who lives down the lane from
1936. uh that's going to be just me
because tom was too sick to record
yesterday
so just a little heads up about that uh
again thanks everybody for dropping by
and we'll see you guys on friday night
bye